Consider for a moment all the art forms that were created on this continent by Americans-- jazz, the blues, musical theater, rock and roll, phonograph recordings themselves, television, motion pictures, video games. I would argue that all of them are eclipsed by the art form at which we truly excel as a nation, the art form which more Americans practice than any other, the art form which actually dominates all the other art forms and our political life as well. And that is the art of selling. That's what we do the most reliably.
试想一下，美国人在这个大陆上创造的所有艺术形式——爵士乐、蓝调、音乐剧、摇滚乐、留声机唱片、电视、电影、电子游戏。我认为，所有这些艺术形式都比不上我们作为一个国家真正擅长的艺术形式，这种艺术形式比其他任何形式都有更多的美国人在实践，它实际上主宰了所有其他艺术形式，也主宰了我们的政治生活。那就是销售的艺术。这是我们做得最可靠的事情。
From Wall Street to the pollsters in market research firms and focus group operations all across the fruited plain, from the telemarketers who phone us during dinner to the junk mailing operations that fill our mailboxes in the morning, from James Carville selling candidates on our televisions to the gang kids on Chicago's West Side selling weed in Humboldt Park, from the corny ads on every other radio station to the pledge drives that I participate in myself on this very station. From sea to shining sea, sales is our great democratic art form. And I would argue, nothing wrong with that. And in any case, we don't have any choice about it, so we might as well decide to feel good about the whole thing.
从华尔街到市场研究公司和焦点小组运作的民调专家，从全美各地在晚餐时间给我们打电话的电话推销员，到每天早上填满我们信箱的垃圾邮件，从在电视上兜售候选人的詹姆斯·卡维尔，到芝加哥西区在洪堡公园卖大麻的帮派少年，从每个电台播放的俗气广告，到我本人也参与的这一电台的认捐活动。从大海到大海，销售是我们伟大的民主艺术形式。我认为，这没什么不对。而且无论如何，我们对此别无选择，所以我们不妨决定对这一切感觉良好。
To help you do that, today on our radio program, inspiring case studies and some horrifying ones too. The whole gamut. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
为了帮助你们做到这一点，今天我们的广播节目将介绍一些鼓舞人心的案例，也有一些令人毛骨悚然的案例。应有尽有。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today's program, Sales. America's greatest art form. Act One of our show today, How To Talk Your Way Into Half A Million Dollars In Just 45 Minutes. In that act, Sandra Tsing Loh accompanies a Hollywood screenwriter, as he tries to sell a movie idea.
今天的节目主题是：销售。美国最伟大的艺术形式。我们今天节目的第一幕，“如何在45分钟内说服他人给你五十万美元”。在这一幕中，桑德拉·青·罗陪伴一位好莱坞编剧尝试推销一个电影构思。
Act Two, Jail Sell. That's S-E-L-L. A story from Danny Hoch in which a true American salesman gets thrown in the slammer for simply being an entrepreneur and has a few words to say about it, believe me.
第二幕，“监狱推销”。拼写是S-E-L-L。这是丹尼·霍克讲述的一个故事，一位真正的美国推销员因为仅仅是做了一个创业者就被关进了监狱，他对此有一些话要说，相信我。
Act Three, Who's The Man? We have this story of how becoming a salesman can change your life, make you more confident, make you able to charm anyone. And why you might decide that that's not such a good thing. Act Four, The Secret To Being Rich And Happy. The life of 76-year-old salesman Jimmy Roy in Braddock, Pennsylvania raises the possibility that being a rich salesman and being a happy salesmen might be mutually exclusive. Stay with us.
第三幕，“谁才是大佬？”我们有这样一个故事：成为一名推销员如何改变你的生活，让你更自信，让你能够吸引任何人。以及为什么你可能会觉得这并不是什么好事。第四幕，“富有且快乐的秘诀”。76岁的推销员吉米·罗在宾夕法尼亚州布拉多克的生活引发了一种可能性，即成为一名富有的推销员和成为一名快乐的推销员可能是相互排斥的。请继续收听。
Act One, How To Talk Your Way Into A Half Million Dollars In Just 45 Minutes. Friends, let us consider one of the many crossroads where art and commerce meet and ask the question, is commerce the greater art than art itself? In our first story today, writer Sandra Tsing Loh takes us into a setting that, as an occasional screenwriter, she knows well herself-- the Hollywood pitch meeting, where movie and TV deals are made.
第一幕，如何在45分钟内说服他人给你五十万美元。朋友们，让我们思考一下艺术与商业相遇的众多十字路口之一，并问一个问题：商业是否比艺术本身更伟大？在今天的第一篇报道中，作家桑德拉·青·罗带我们进入了一个她作为偶尔从事编剧工作的人非常熟悉的场景——好莱坞推销会议，电影和电视交易就是在这里达成的。
And we thought we would start our show here because it is a sales situation where the stakes are enormously high, where things are decided very quickly, and where people who often like to think of themselves as artists-- I mean, writers, and producers, and people like that-- are basically forced to be salesmen. Here's Sandra.
我们想从这里开始我们的节目，因为这是一个赌注极高的销售情境，事情决定得非常快，而且那些经常自认为是艺术家的人——我是说，作家、制片人等等——基本上被迫成为推销员。这是桑德拉。
I'm with writer Scott Fifer two days before a big movie pitch meeting. We're in his small office nested deep in an office building on Wilshire, where Scott works on the writing staff of Beverly Hills, 90210, a waning Spelling TV show about increasingly long-in-the-tooth teens. It's not where he wants to be forever. What Scott really wants to do is write movies, big, funny movies. And he's had some luck.
我和作家斯科特·菲弗在一起，距离一场大型电影推销会议还有两天。我们在他位于威尔希尔一栋办公楼深处的小办公室里，斯科特在电视剧《飞越比弗利》的编剧组工作，这是一部斯佩林制作的日渐衰落的电视节目，讲的是一群越来越老的青少年。这不是他想永远待的地方。斯科特真正想做的是写电影，那种大而有趣的电影。他运气还不错。
Four years ago, he sold a pitch to Columbia-- a kind of Lysistrata, but with football widows-- and was paid to write the script. Although it's now in turnaround, hiatus, limbo, no more money will be forthcoming, et cetera. Scott knows he's a good pitcher and writer and that he has a really funny, new movie idea, which he's pitched, so far, to seven producers.
四年前，他向哥伦比亚影业推销了一个构思——有点像《利西翠妲》，但是讲的是橄榄球遗孀的故事——并获得了剧本创作费。虽然现在项目处于停滞状态，处于搁置或悬而未决的尴尬境地，不会再有钱进账等等。斯科特知道他是一个很好的推销员和作家，而且他有一个非常有趣的、新的电影构思，目前为止他已经向七位制片人推销过。
In fact, every producer I've gone to has responded very positively and very excited. So that gets me excited. And I think, "Wow, this is going to sell. I'm going to sell this pitch. I'm going to be rich."
事实上，我接触的每一位制片人都反应非常积极，非常兴奋。这让我很兴奋。我觉得，“哇，这肯定能卖出去。我会卖掉这个构思。我会发财的。”
So what happened with those seven so far?
那么那七个构思后来怎么样了？
They didn't sell, and I'm not rich.
都没卖出去，我也没有发财。
Friday is pitch number eight. In the movie industry, different salesmen have different styles. Scott approaches the pitch like a performance piece. He acts out the whole movie, goes into different character voices, loads on a lot of detail.
周五是第八次推销。在电影行业，不同的推销员有不同的风格。斯科特把推销当作表演。他把整部电影演出来，模拟不同的角色声音，添加大量的细节。
I am a little worried that I'm giving them too much information. My pitches tend to be a little long. They go about 20 minutes. And I know other people that pitch just the trailer to the movie.
我有点担心我给他们的信息太多了。我的推销通常有点长。大约20分钟。我知道其他人只推销电影的预告片。
I was talking to Andrew Marlowe, who did Air Force One. And when he goes into a pitch, he's just like, "Arnold Schwarzenegger coming back from the dead and meeting Satan. And he turns to the camera and says, 'I'll meet you in hell.'" And that's all he has to do when he sells a million dollar pitch.
我曾与做过《空军一号》的安德鲁·马洛交谈。当他进行推销时，他只是说：“阿诺德·施瓦辛格死而复生遇见了撒旦。他转向镜头说：‘我在地狱等你。’”他推销百万美元的剧本时只需做这些。
What's the secret to a million dollar pitch? Before we head out to the big meeting, for a quick primer on pitching theory, I turn to veteran pitcher Bob Kosberg, reputed king of the one-line pitch, currently a producer at Merv Griffin Productions.
百万美元推销的秘诀是什么？在我们前往那场大会议之前，为了快速了解推销理论，我请教了资深推销员鲍勃·科斯伯格，他被誉为“单句推销之王”，目前是默夫·格里芬制作公司的制片人。
I don't know that they're great or that they're legendary. But I can give you examples of pitches that we've sold that had those one-line, two-line hooks to them or premises that were very high concept that when an executive heard it, they right away got the idea. We sold a project called Man's Best Friend, which was really about a dog that had been genetically enhanced and then went out of control. But the key line that sold it was to then say, "In other words, Mr. Executive, it's basically Jaws on paws."
我不知道它们是否伟大或传奇。但我可以给你们举一些我们卖掉的推销案例，它们都有那些一两句话的钩子，或者是非常高概念的前提，当高管听到时，他们立刻就明白了。我们卖掉了一个叫《人类最好的朋友》的项目，讲的是一只被基因增强然后失控的狗。但卖掉它的关键台词是：“换句话说，高管先生，这基本上就是《大白鲨》装了爪子。”
And then the Jaws with paws doesn't make it a better movie, but it makes the executive remember it better?
那么“装了爪子的《大白鲨》”并没有让电影变得更好，但让高管更容易记住了？
It makes the executive remember it. It's a cute, little, glib sales tool that will allow them to take your pitch and go down the hall, remember as much of the pitch as they can. But then in the middle of while they're forgetting it, they can say, "But I remember the poster. It's sort of Jaws on paws." Then they can get the laugh. It's like telling a good joke. The joke travels well down the executive corridors.
这让高管记住了它。这是一种可爱、简短、油嘴滑舌的销售工具，让他们可以拿着你的推销构思沿着大厅走，尽可能多地记住推销内容。但是当他们记不全的时候，他们可以说：“但我记得那个海报，它有点像装了爪子的《大白鲨》。”然后他们就能博得一笑。就像讲一个好笑话。笑话在行政走廊里传得很快。
We sold a story called Busby to Turner. That was a fun pitch because we actually brought a dog. Everyone knows the Taco Bell chihuahua. Well, a few years ago, there was a dog that was very hot from another movie. At this point, I'm trying to remember which dog it even was. I think it was the dog from As Good As It Gets.
我们向特纳电视台卖了一个叫《巴斯比》的故事。那是一次有趣的推销，因为我们真的带了一只狗。每个人都知道塔可钟的吉娃娃。嗯，几年前，有一只狗在另一部电影中非常火。此刻，我正试图回忆那到底是哪只狗。我想是《尽善尽美》里的那只狗。
But we took that dog around to the studios to pitch meetings. And the dog would sit at attention with a pencil in his mouth like he was ready to take notes. But ultimately, the pitch was the story-- Busby was the story of two guys who wanted to steal the world's smartest dog right off of a studio lot. "The dog was working at Paramount," we said, "making a movie called Bite Hard III."
但我们带着那只狗去制片厂参加推销会议。那只狗会坐着，嘴里叼着铅笔，好像准备做笔记一样。但最终，推销的是故事——《巴斯比》的故事是关于两个想从制片厂里偷走世界上最聪明的狗的家伙。“那只狗在派拉蒙工作，”我们说，“正在拍一部叫《重咬三》的电影。”
Well, once we got to the point in the story where we could say, "These kidnappers break on to the studio lot, steal the dog, and bring it back, and wait for the phone to ring," we could stop the pitch and say, "Basically, it's Ruthless People with a dog." And it helped that the dog was in the room. So sometimes, I'm not above cheap stunts.
好吧，当我们讲到故事中可以说“这两个绑匪闯入制片厂，偷走了狗，把它带回来，等待电话响”的时候，我们就可以停下来推销说：“基本上，这就是带狗版的《小迷糊闯七关》。”而且狗在房间里也有帮助。所以有时候，我也会用一些廉价的特技。
As Kosberg goes on to describe other legendary pitches he has sold-- Norma Rae with long legs, The Lust Boat, a Bette Midler fertility clinic mix-up caper called Scrambled Eggs-- I realize that, paradoxically, I'm much more entertained by the pitches than, well, I'd probably be by the actual movies they'd spawned. Think about it. While the phrase " Jaws with paws" is a laugh, the 90-minute hilarious summer movie version of Jaws with paws with a car chase, and a teen romance, and a wacky cameo by the comedian Sinbad sounds a little painful, which makes me wonder. Have we come to a point in Hollywood history when the pitches have become better than the movies? When the pitches themselves are somehow a purer form of movie? Bob Kosberg says, "Sure. And why not?"
当科斯伯格继续描述他卖掉的其他传奇推销——长腿版《诺玛·蕾》、《欲望之船》、《碎蛋》（一部贝特·米德勒主演的关于生育诊所弄错孩子的闹剧）——我意识到，矛盾的是，比起这些构思可能催生的电影，我对推销本身更感兴趣。想一想。虽然“装了爪子的《大白鲨》”是个笑话，但如果真拍成90分钟的《大白鲨》欢乐夏日电影，加上飞车追逐、青春恋情，还有喜剧演员辛巴达的客串，听起来就有点痛苦，这让我怀疑。我们是否已经到了好莱坞历史上推销比电影本身更好的地步？推销本身是否成了某种更纯粹的电影形式？鲍勃·科斯伯格说：“当然。为什么不呢？”
Well, that's one of the wonderful things about pitching. When you're pitching the story in the first meetings, everybody visualizes the movie they want to see. It can only be the best possible version at that moment. It can only get worse from that point on because then you have to write the darn thing and directors come in with their version.
嗯，这是推销的美妙之处之一。当你在第一次会议中推销故事时，每个人都会想象他们想看的电影。在那一刻，它只能是最好的版本。从那时起它只会变得更糟，因为你必须把它写出来，导演也会带着他们的版本加入。
And now, of course, to give credit to all the talented people of Hollywood, sometimes they take a pitch, and the writer, the director, the stars, the studio make it better. But you're right. A lot of times, when you're just pitching, what's great about that stage of the development process is it's all about potential.
当然，现在为了肯定好莱坞所有有才华的人，有时他们会采纳一个构思，然后作家、导演、明星、制片厂会让它变得更好。但你说得对。很多时候，当你只是在推销时，开发过程中那个阶段的伟大之处在于它全是关于潜力。
Scott Fifer-- and remember that his brilliant Lysistrata football-widows pitch is now lost in turnaround limbo-- couldn't agree more.
斯科特·菲弗——请记住他那绝妙的《利西翠妲》橄榄球遗孀推销构思现在正迷失在停滞的尴尬境地——对此深表赞同。
That may very well be true. It's sad, but true that the pitch is as good as it's going to get. And it's just downhill from there. You keep getting notes on how to change it, and why it should be different, and all these other people start adding their opinions.
那可能确实是真的。很悲哀，但推销确实是它能达到的最好水平了。从那以后就是走下坡路。你会不断收到关于如何修改它的建议，为什么它应该有所不同，以及所有这些其他人开始加入他们的意见。
And it's frustrating that I still can think of that pitch and think, "My god, that's such a great idea. That's such a movie. I can see it. It stars Julia Roberts. I love it." And it may never happen. And that's so frustrating.
最令人沮丧的是，我依然能想起那个推销，觉得“天哪，那真是个绝妙的主意。那真是一部电影。我可以预见它。由朱莉娅·罗伯茨主演。我爱死它了。”但它可能永远不会发生。这太让人沮丧了。
To avoid frustration, Scott knows that the producers he's pitching to Friday are looking specifically for a Liar Liar type comedy, which is the very type of movie he's pitching. Although, depending on his audience, he can also pitch it as a Dumb And Dumber comedy or a Nutty Professor comedy. How will he know his pitch is succeeding? When the executives laugh. Who is he pitching to? Two successful and in-demand producers, whose most recent movie is being released by Dreamworks, Dan Jinks and Bruce Cohen.
为了避免沮丧，斯科特知道周五他要向其推销的制片人正在专门寻找那种《大话王》风格的喜剧，这正是他正在推销的电影类型。虽然根据观众的不同，他也可以将其推销为《阿呆与阿瓜》喜剧或《肥佬教授》喜剧。他怎么知道他的推销成功了？当高管们笑的时候。他在向谁推销？两位成功且炙手可热的制片人，他们最近的电影正由梦工厂发行，丹·金克斯和布鲁斯·科恩。
I am sure that I met these people once. But sometimes, they might not remember me because they meet more writers than I meet producers. It helps if you know the people because it is much less comfortable when you're pitching to a complete stranger. So it would be nice if they actually have some recognition when they look in my eyes.
我确定我见过这些人一次。但有时，他们可能不记得我，因为他们见的作家比我见的制片人多。如果你认识这些人会有所帮助，因为当你向完全陌生的人推销时，会很不自在。所以如果他们看着我的眼睛时真的能认出我，那会很好。
They don't.
他们没有。
Hey. Scott.
嘿。斯科特。
Nice to meet you, Scott. Dan Jinks. How are you?
很高兴见到你，斯科特。我是丹·金克斯。你好吗？
I'm Sandra. It's nice--
我是桑德拉。很高兴——
Sandra, how are you? We've met before.
桑德拉，你好吗？我们以前见过。
Yes, we have. We have.
是的，我们见过。确实见过。
I don't think I've never met before. But I read you. You wrote Starstruck?
我不认为我见过。但我读过你的作品。你写了《星光熠熠》？
Yes. Though actually, we have met. But that's OK.
是的。虽然实际上，我们见过面。不过没关系。
I couldn't remember.
我记不清了。
There's a lot of mes, and not a lot of yous. I came to your house up in the Hollywood Hills.
有很多个像我这样的人，而像你们这样的人不多。我曾去过你们在好莱坞山的房子。
That's right.
那是真的。
Now let me cue you in to what's physically happening. Dan Jinks and Bruce Cohen, the producers, are settling themselves into chairs on the right side of the room, which is fairly bare. These are relatively new offices, ones they've just moved into. Scott, looking subtly natty, and yet casual, in black, button-down DKNY shirt and black jeans, is settling himself into a chair on the left. What's extraordinary, given the clear division between seller and buyer-- I mean Scott is here to pitch an idea which Dan and Bruce will either buy or reject. It'll be over as soon as he leaves the room, possibly even before he leaves the room.
现在让我告诉你发生了什么。制片人丹·金克斯和布鲁斯·科恩在房间右侧的椅子上坐下，房间里相当空。这些是相对较新的办公室，他们刚搬进来。斯科特穿着黑色的DKNY纽扣衬衫和黑色牛仔裤，显得微妙而时髦，又很随性，在左侧的椅子上坐下。鉴于买卖双方之间明显的界限——我的意思是斯科特在这里推销一个丹和布鲁斯要么买要么拒绝的构思——这非常非同寻常。他一离开房间这一切就结束了，甚至可能在他离开房间之前就结束了。
Anyway, what's extraordinary, given that there are literally hundreds of thousands of dollars at stake, is the intense sense of casualness, openness, even democracy, in the room. Everyone's 30-ish or so. No one's in a suit. It's as if the stakes are so frighteningly high that the only way anyone could get through this is if everyone does their best to pretend nothing's at stake. And so the producers are bantering with us. And, more importantly, they are practicing that peculiar playing-field-leveling gambit you might think of as "The ritual of the water."
无论如何，考虑到实际上有成千上万的美元悬而未决，最非同寻常的是房间里那种强烈的随意感、开放感，甚至是民主。每个人都在30岁左右。没有人穿西装。就好像赌注高得令人恐惧，以至于任何人能挺过这一关的唯一方法就是每个人都尽最大努力假装没有任何赌注。所以制片人们在和我们开玩笑。更重要的是，他们正在练习那种你们可以称之为“水的仪式”的独特的拉平竞争环境的策略。
How's everyone? Do you want waters?
大家怎么样？要喝水吗？
I would like some, please.
我想要一点，谢谢。
Yeah.
好的。
Can I tell you the exciting thing is that we were renting furniture here. And now we've bought furniture, but we don't have a couch yet, so this is why-- oh, who didn't get a water? You didn't get a water. Anyway, so--
我可以告诉你一件令人兴奋的事，我们之前一直在这里租家具。现在我们买了家具，但还没有沙发，所以这就是为什么——噢，谁没拿到水？你没拿到水。总之，所以——
In a nutshell, here's what the plastic bottled water, traveling hand to hand, from producer-- buyer-- to writer-- seller-- tends to mean. And the water always travels buyer to seller. Do writers ever bring producers bottles of water when they pitch? No.
简而言之，这种从制片人（买方）传到作家（卖方）手中的塑料瓶装水往往意味着什么。而且水总是从买方传向卖方。作家在推销时会给制片人带瓶装水吗？不会。
Anyway, in my personal experience, the water is a courtesy gesture that always implies a lack of something. At the beginning of a meeting, "We don't know you. Have a water." In the middle of a meeting, "Leslie Ann here, may be nothing more than a poorly-paid intern, but even she deserves a water." At the end of a meeting for an unsuccessful pitch, "In lieu of actual money, here, take an extra water." At this moment, rolling around on the floor of my car, are literally about a dozen half-filled plastic bottles of water.
总之，根据我的个人经验，水是一种礼貌的姿态，总是暗示着某种东西的缺失。会议开始时，“我们不认识你。喝点水吧。”会议中间，“这边的莱斯利·安可能只是一个薪水微薄的实习生，但即使是她也应该有一瓶水。”会议结束时，对于推销不成功的会议，“没钱给，给你瓶水吧。”此刻，我的车地板上翻滚着大概十二瓶喝了一半的塑料瓶装水。
What the water is, also, is a banter helper. The pre-pitch banter, of course, being another key democratizing ritual. "How was your drive over? Did you find our office OK?" "Yes, I did. But that left turn onto Santa Monica, I hate that turn."
水也是一种玩笑助手。推销前的寒暄当然是另一种关键的民主化仪式。“开车过来怎么样？找到我们办公室了吗？”“是的，找到了。但是圣莫尼卡那个左转，我讨厌那个转弯。”
The four basic modes of executive banter are, one, how was your drive over? Two, we know some of the same people. Three, I was just reviewing your work, which I followed for many years, and thinking how much I especially loved your piece on-- you'd be surprised how rarely that happens. And finally, of course, there's the dreaded four. "Sorry you had to wait for 40 minutes. It's just that my son's 10th birthday party is happening on Saturday, and the whole household is in an uproar."
高管寒暄的四种基本模式是：一，开车过来怎么样？二，我们认识一些共同的朋友。三，我刚审阅了你的作品，我已经关注很多年了，想到我特别喜欢你关于……你可能会惊讶这种事情很少发生。最后，当然还有令人畏惧的第四种。“抱歉让你等了40分钟。只是因为我儿子的10岁生日聚会要在周六举行，家里乱成一团。”
In general, the actual content of the banter is less important than how long it lasts, which is always a delicate matter. As the pitcher, you don't necessarily want to be the first to cut the banter off, abruptly transitioning a warm, us-focused human room into a crude, me-focused "Have I got something to sell you" room. Also, if an executive encourages a long period of banter, it can be a good thing because it means "I'm loving this conversation. I'm loving you. Eddie Murphy enjoys working with down-to-earth people. Let's make a deal."
通常，寒暄的实际内容不如它持续的时间重要，这总是一个微妙的问题。作为推销员，你并不想成为第一个突兀地切断寒暄的人，将一个温暖的、以我们为中心的人性化房间变成一个粗鲁的、以我为中心的“我有东西要卖给你”的房间。此外，如果一位高管鼓励长时间的寒暄，这可能是一件好事，因为它意味着“我喜欢这次谈话。我喜欢你。艾迪·墨菲喜欢和脚踏实地的人一起工作。让我们达成协议吧。”
On the other hand, it can go on too long. I once went to a pitch meeting at a major television network, where the executive told hilarious stories about herself for 45 minutes out of a 1 hour meeting, with apparently huge enjoyment, eliciting regular, rhythmic howls of laughter from her sub-executives. She had literally talked so long, I'd forgotten why I was there or what I was supposed to be pitching. All I was aware of was of my body tossing forward and back with the others, slaves rowing together in a kind of merciless comedy galley of hilarity. Perhaps you've noticed the hilarious TV sitcom Suddenly Sandra wasn't on last fall's schedule.
另一方面，它可能持续太久。我曾经去过一家主要电视台的推销会议，那位高管在一小时的会议中讲了45分钟关于她自己的搞笑故事，显然非常享受，并不时引起她的下属高管阵阵节奏性的笑声。她讲得实在太久，以至于我忘了我为什么来这里，或者我应该推销什么。我只意识到我的身体随着其他人前后晃动，就像在一种无情的喜剧划船机里一起划船的奴隶。也许你注意到了搞笑的情景喜剧《桑德拉突发事件》去年秋天没有上档。
Scott's transition from banter into the very act of selling is perfectly smooth. He unobtrusively takes out a stack of his three-by-five cards and says,
斯科特从寒暄过渡到销售行为的过程非常顺畅。他不动声色地拿出那叠3x5卡片说：
Anyway.
总之。
So I have this pitch for you.
所以我有一个构思要推销给你们。
Yes.
好的。
Wonderful.
太棒了。
And I don't know if you know too much about it.
我不知道你们对它了解多少。
I don't think I have any idea what it is. So I'm excited.
我想我完全不知道是什么。所以我很兴奋。
All right. Well, I'll tell you it's a comedy. And that it's in the vein of Liar Liar. I used that as my role model because I figured, that's a great way to go.
好的。嗯，我告诉你们，这是一个喜剧。它和《大话王》是一个路数的。我用它作为我的榜样，因为我想，这是一个很好的方向。
I like it a lot actually.
我其实非常喜欢。
Exactly. So if you're ready.
正是如此。所以如果你准备好了。
We're ready.
我们准备好了。
Our hero is TC-- Jim Carrey, Eddie Murphy, Adam Sandler-- he runs a Mrs. Goody's. Think of Mrs. Field's store. And he hates it. He hates rolling the dough, hates baking the cookies. He hates being nice to his picky customers we see. And he hates the sappy logo, which is a saccharine photo of Mrs. Goody herself, TC's mother.
我们的主人公是TC——像吉姆·凯瑞、艾迪·墨菲、亚当·桑德勒那样的人——他经营一家“古迪太太”店。想象一下“菲尔德太太”那种店。但他讨厌它。他讨厌揉面团，讨厌烤饼干。他讨厌对那些挑剔的顾客表现得很好。他讨厌那个感情用事的标志，那是TC的母亲、“古迪太太”本人的一张甜腻的照片。
The premise Scott is moving toward, what's calculated to strike the listener at about minute six or seven of the pitch, is what if all the sayings your mother ever said to you came true? An apple a day keeps the doctor away. Frown in your face will stay that way. Swallow a watermelon seed, and a watermelon will grow in your stomach, et cetera.
斯科特正在推进的前提，也就是旨在在推销进行到第六或第七分钟时打动听众的是，如果你的母亲对你说的所有话都成真了会怎样？一天一个苹果，医生远离我。皱眉头脸就会一直那样。吞下西瓜籽，胃里就会长出西瓜，等等。
It's commercial. It's funny. It's well worked out. And yet, as Scott pitches on, exuding confidence, calmly flipping his index cards, I remember a thing he'd said to me on Wednesday.
它很有商业价值。它很有趣。它构思得很好。然而，当斯科特继续推销，流露出自信，冷静地翻动他的索引卡片时，我记得他在周三对我说过的话。
When they're not laughing, if there's a long gap, it probably makes me talk faster. Because then I think, "All right, I'm losing them. I've got to speed up here and get to the next funny point." So if I even speed up and talk faster than I was before, which is almost impossible, then you know I think I'm in trouble. And I'm just trying to get to something even funnier. And I'm flipping through the cards like, "When's the next funny thing?"
当他们不笑的时候，如果有一段很长的空白，可能会让我说得更快。因为那时我想，“好吧，我失去他们了。我得加快速度，讲到下一个笑点。”所以如果我甚至比以前说得更快，这几乎是不可能的，那你就会知道我觉得自己有麻烦了。我只是想讲点更有趣的事情。我翻着卡片想着：“下一个笑点什么时候到？”
And now, midway through the pitch, I realize Scott is literally talking faster than I've ever heard him-- or really, any other living human being-- talk before.
现在，推销进行到一半，我意识到斯科特的语速简直是我听过他——或者任何其他活人——说话最快的一次。
TC's completely stuffed, but he has to eat it all because of the starving kids in Africa. So now he's comically gobbling down food. He doesn't want it. It's not the romantic evening he planned at all. Now the CEO is always--
TC完全吃撑了，但他必须把它全部吃掉，因为非洲有挨饿的孩子。所以现在他滑稽地狼吞虎咽地吃着食物。他根本不想吃。这根本不是他计划中的浪漫夜晚。现在首席执行官总是——
Throughout all this, Bruce occasionally laughs. But Dan makes no sound at all. He just sits there, smiling. Is it a warm smile? A civil smile? I can't tell. Around minute 13 though, when Scott gets to the big masturbation joke, he clearly starts to win them over. And, to my surprise and relief, the ending of the pitch is warm.
在整个过程中，布鲁斯偶尔会笑。但丹一声不吭。他只是坐在那儿，微笑着。这是温暖的微笑吗？礼貌的微笑？我看不出来。不过在大约第13分钟，当斯科特讲到那个关于手淫的大笑话时，他显然开始赢得他们了。而且，让我惊讶和宽慰的是，推销的结尾很温暖。
But he gives him a long, passionate kiss to hold him over. And he thanks her and asks her if she has any carrots because he's going to need them in the morning. The end.
但他给了她一个长长而热情的吻来安慰她。他感谢她，并问她是否有胡萝卜，因为他明天早上需要它们。结束。
Bravo.
太棒了。
There you go.
就是这样。
Can I have some water?
我能喝点水吗？
I will tell you my thoughts. Are you open to hearing thoughts and suggestions about it?
我会告诉你我的想法。你愿意听听关于它的想法和建议吗？
Of course.
当然。
I really like it a lot. I had a couple of thoughts. Right now, the way you describe this guy is he seems like he's almost too much of a schmuck. It's hard for us, as an audience, to care about what happens to him. And I think that to make this movie work better, I think that we need to have an investment in his story and in him.
我真的很喜欢它。我有几个想法。现在，你描述这个家伙的方式，他看起来几乎太像个笨蛋了。作为观众，我们很难关心他身上会发生什么。我认为为了让这部电影效果更好，我们需要对他的故事和他本人有所投入。
Dan and Bruce critique the pitch for 10 minutes, an unusually long time. And it's hard to know how to read this. Does this mean they're interested? Or that they hate it?
丹和布鲁斯对这个构思进行了10分钟的批评，时间异常长。很难判断如何解读这个。这是否意味着他们感兴趣？还是他们讨厌它？
And then, at the end, their final question is, "Have our notes made sense to you?" They don't promise they'll call or consult with others in their production company. This does not seem to bode well.
然后，最后，他们的问题是，“我们的建议对你有意义吗？”他们没有承诺会打电话或咨询制作公司的其他人。这看起来并不乐观。
Well, thanks for listening.
好吧，谢谢你们的倾听。
Thank you for--
谢谢你——
Thanks for coming in and telling  it to us.
谢谢你过来告诉我们。
Now the only thing that remains is the long walk to the elevator. Before we leave the building, I make Scott duck into the only private place I can think of, the ladies lounge, for a quick post-mortem.
现在唯一剩下的就是去电梯的长路。在我们离开大楼之前，我让斯科特溜进我能想到的唯一私人地方——女士休息室，进行快速的总结。
So how do you feel the pitch went from your side? Obviously, it went great. But what was the experience like for you?
那么你觉得你的推销进行得怎么样？很明显，进行得很棒。但对你来说体验如何？
I felt it went well. I could tell that they were into it. They were paying attention. I didn't feel like it was the greatest pitch, but I could tell it was going well.
我觉得进行得很顺利。我能看出他们很投入。他们很专注。我觉得这不算是最棒的推销，但我能看出进行得很顺利。
Into the ladies lounge suddenly appears a lady.
女士休息室里突然出现了一位女士。
I'm sorry. We're just finishing an interview. Go through. Sorry. So any other thoughts about how it went?
对不起。我们刚结束采访。请过。抱歉。那么关于推销情况还有什么想法吗？
No, they gave a lot of notes, which usually-- I'm surprised they gave so many notes. That was more than I expected and, sometimes, more than you want. Because you're just like, "All right. You know what? I just did it. I'm done here. You decide. Let me go home. I don't need to hear your philosophies on filmmaking."
没有，他们给了很多建议，通常——我很惊讶他们给了这么多建议。这比我预期的要多，有时，比你想要的还要多。因为你会想，“好吧。你知道吗？我刚做完了。我在这里结束了。你们决定吧。让我回家吧。我不需要听你们关于电影制作的哲学。”
But their notes were good. I think they're just tweaking notes. And they were just little things. They weren't about major-- I think it maybe a matter of them, how they perceive some things. Or maybe I spoke too fast. And just hitting different points and emphasizing. So their notes were fine. And I agreed with them.
但他们的建议很好。我认为他们只是微调建议。而且只是小事情。它们不是关于重大的——我想这可能是他们感知某些事物的方式问题。或者也许我说得太快了。只是触及不同的点并强调。所以他们的建议很好。我同意他们。
Scott heads to the elevator, and I walk back into the producers' offices for a quick Siskel & Ebert on Scott's performance.
斯科特走向电梯，我走回制片人的办公室，对斯科特的表现进行快速的《西斯克尔与埃伯特》式点评。
So what's your feedback on that pitch? How was that in the pitch? Do you think you're going to buy it or go with it or something?
那么你们对那个推销有什么反馈？推销进行得怎么样？你们觉得会买下它或者继续推进吗？
Yeah, what we'll do now is talk to-- obviously, we'll talk to each other. But because we talked a lot, I think we're pretty much in agreement. We'll call Adam Shulman and Brant Rose, who are Scott's agents, and have a conversation with them about taking this into studios.
是的，我们现在要做的就是谈谈——显然，我们会彼此沟通。但因为我们谈了很多，我想我们基本上达成了一致。我们会给亚当·舒尔曼和布兰特·罗斯打电话，他们是斯科特的经纪人，和他们谈谈把它推向制片厂的事情。
And so good news for Scott Fifer. He sold the pitch. A half a million dollars could be his. But first, Dan, Bruce, and Scott have to go out and pitch the project to a studio. The studio will go out and pitch the project to directors and stars.
所以对于斯科特·菲弗来说是好消息。他卖掉了这个构思。五十万美元可能是他的了。但首先，丹、布鲁斯和斯科特必须出去向制片厂推销这个项目。制片厂会去向导演和明星推销这个项目。
If they make the movie and are successful in pitching it to theater owners, in order to get the widest possible distribution, then the actors will take it out into the public. It'll be Jim Carrey, Eddie Murphy, or Adam Sandler sitting on that chair next to Jay Leno, bottle of water in hand. And after some preliminary banter, when asked what the movie's about, if they're lucky, they'll be able to say, "Well, it's kind of a Jaws with paws." And the studio audience will erupt.
如果他们拍了这部电影，并且在向影院老板推销时获得成功，为了获得尽可能广泛的发行，那么演员们会把它带给公众。到时候会是吉姆·凯瑞、艾迪·墨菲或亚当·桑德勒坐在杰·雷诺旁边的椅子上，手里拿着一瓶水。在一些初步的寒暄之后，当被问及电影讲什么时，如果他们幸运的话，他们能说：“嗯，这有点像带爪子的《大白鲨》。”然后现场观众会爆发出欢呼。
Sandra Tsing Loh's off-Broadway show Aliens in America opens in Los Angeles this August at the Tiffany Theater for a limited run. She's writing an original screenplay for Dreamworks.
桑德拉·青·罗的外百老汇演出《美国的异形》将于今年8月在洛杉矶的蒂芙尼剧院限量演出。她正在为梦工厂编写一部原创剧本。
Act Two, Jail Sell. You could argue, and in fact I am arguing it for the purpose of today's program, that selling is what this country is all about. So imagine the outrage when people are thrown in jail for doing nothing more than being salesmen, for being so profoundly American. This comes up in Danny Hoch's show, Jails, Hospitals and Hip-Hop.
第二幕，“监狱推销”。你们可以说，事实上我为了今天的节目目的正在论证这一点，销售是这个国家的一切。所以，想象一下，当人们仅仅因为是推销员、因为如此深刻的美国式行为而被投入监狱时，那是何等的愤怒。这出现在丹尼·霍克的演出《监狱、医院和嘻哈》中。
The guy who tells this particular story is a guy who has been locked up for selling. A warning to sensitive listeners. There are no nasty words in this story. But I have to say, there are a lot of beeps.
讲述这个特别故事的家伙是一个因为销售而被关起来的家伙。给敏感听众的警告。这个故事里没有脏话。但我必须说，有很多“哔”的声音。
Yo, trust me, man. Just plead guilty, guilty, guilty. Me, I got totally different problems, man. I try to do the right thing. They lock me up.
伙计，相信我。只要认罪，认罪，认罪。我，我有完全不同的问题，伙计。我试着做正确的事。他们把我关起来。
You know, Giuliani's like, "People on welfare are lazy." I'm trying not to be on that [BLEEP], right? I'm working. I'm in Fordham Road. I'm selling Bart Simpson t-shirts and-- what you call it-- OJ Simpson t-shirts, right?
你知道，朱利安尼说，“领福利的人很懒。”我试着不成为那样的人，对吧？我在工作。我在福特汉姆路。我在卖巴特·辛普森的T恤和——你们叫什么——OJ·辛普森的T恤，对吧？
This cop come out and arrest me because I don't got a license. All right? I'm not selling drugs. I'm selling drugs. I'm selling Bart Simpson, OJ Simpson t-shirts.
这个警察出来逮捕我，因为我没有执照。好吗？我没在卖毒品。我是在卖毒品。我是在卖巴特·辛普森、OJ·辛普森的T恤。
That's work, man. You think that [BLEEP] is easy? That [BLEEP] is hard. I don't even want to go into it. No, but they said, it's illegal. That's not legal. Come on.
那是工作，伙计。你以为那玩意儿很容易吗？那玩意儿很难。我甚至不想细说。不，但他们说，这是违法的。那不合法。得了吧。
I try to do right in my life, man. I want to be an entrepreneur or whatever you call it. No, you know if I was that little girl that they show in that commercial selling lemonade in front of her house, you think the cop gonna arrest her? Nah-uh. Nah-uh.
我试着在生活中做正确的事，伙计。我想成为一名创业者还是随便你们叫什么。不，你知道如果我是他们在广告里展示的那个在房子前卖柠檬水的那个小女孩，你以为警察会逮捕她吗？不会。不会。
But you see, what it is, if you think about it, the little girl, she's an entrepreneur just like me, man. She's a businesswoman. She got-- what you call it-- overhead, right? She got to get her sugar, her lemons, her cups. Then she make her little stand. And she stand outside all day, right?
但你看，是什么呢，如果你仔细想想，那个小女孩，她和我一样是个创业者，伙计。她是个女商人。她有——你们叫什么——间接成本，对吧？她得买糖、柠檬、杯子。然后她做出她的小摊。然后她整天站在外面，对吧？
Me, I got my shirts. I got my stand. I stand outside all day, right? But you know the cop gonna see her in front of her little white picket fence or whatever, he gonna be like, "Oh," all jolly and [BLEEP], right? "Let me get a lemonade, sweetheart. Mmm. Tasty." Whatever, whatever, right?
我，我有我的衬衫。我有我的摊位。我整天站在外面，对吧？但你知道警察会在她那小白栅栏或者其他什么东西前面看到她，他会表现得像，“哦，”很愉快，对吧？“让我买杯柠檬水，亲爱的。嗯。真好喝。”随便吧，随便吧，对吧？
Then he leave. Then he go beat up some people, right? Then he go home. Then he [BLEEP] his wife. Then he think, "Oh, it's not really such a bad day today. God bless America." Right?
然后他离开。然后他去揍一些人，对吧？然后他回家。然后他干他的老婆。然后他想，“哦，今天其实不是那么糟糕的一天。上帝保佑美国。”对吧？
But then he see me on Fordham Road. Aha, different story. He step to me like this, "Hey you, where's your [BLEEP] license?" He gonna say, "Where's your [BLEEP] license?" to the little girl? Nah-uh. Nah-uh.
但然后他在福特汉姆路看到我。啊哈，情况不同了。他向我走来就像这样，“嘿，你，你的执照在哪儿？”他会对那个小女孩说“你的执照在哪儿”吗？不会。不会。
But you see, what is it? If you think about it, in the car, you don't give a [BLEEP] I don't got a license. He doesn't like the way I look, right?
但你看，这是什么呢？如果你仔细想想，在车里，你根本不在乎我有没有执照。他不喜欢我的长相，对吧？
I live in 163rd Street. I got a certain look, whatever. People in Park Avenue, they got a certain look, whatever, right? But you know the cop gonna see somebody from Park Avenue or Tribeca, right? Hauling two kilos of cocaine to their girlfriend's house in their designer [BLEEP] rollerblades or whatever, right? He's not gonna get disturbed about their look, right?
我住在163街。我有某种长相，不管怎样。公园大道的人，他们有某种长相，不管怎样，对吧？但你知道警察会看到公园大道或翠贝卡的人，对吧？穿着他们设计师的轮滑鞋，运送两公斤可卡因到女朋友家，对吧？他不会因为他们的长相感到困扰，对吧？
Probably say, you know, "How you doing? Have a donut. Okey-dokey, buddy." Or whatever the [BLEEP] he say, right?
大概会说，“你好吗？来个甜甜圈。好的，伙计。”或者不管他妈说什么，对吧？
But then you see somebody that looks-- I don't even know what you call it-- unprofessional, whatever, he automatically think criminal, right? So he gets out the car with all his cops [BLEEP] like this, right? Well, see, he has sunglasses in the car. So when he look at me first from the car, I look darker. When he get out, he get confused. Nah, 'cause you put me next to the car, I'm more white than the cop.
但然后你看到一个长相——我甚至不知道怎么叫——不专业，不管怎样，他自动认为就是罪犯，对吧？所以他带着他所有警察那一套从车里出来，像这样，对吧？嗯，看，他车里有墨镜。所以当他第一次从车里看我时，我看起来更黑。当他出来时，他困惑了。不，因为你把我放在车旁边，我比那个警察更白。
So he gets confused. He says, "Whoa, hold up. What are you?" I said, "That's not your business. You want to buy a shirt, right?" Next thing I know, he knock over all my [BLEEP]. The shirts in the street. Everything's dirty, right? I have dirty [BLEEP] products. Everybody pointing at me and laughing and [BLEEP].
所以他困惑了。他说，“哇，等一下。你是什么？”我说，“那不关你的事。你想买件衬衫，对吧？”接下来我知道的是，他撞翻了我所有的东西。衬衫在街上。一切都脏了，对吧？我有了脏兮兮的产品。每个人都指着我笑。
Next thing I know, he throw me in the ground. He got his nightstick in my back with the spit and the gum from the sidewalk is in my face and [BLEEP]. He said, "What are you? What are you? Are you Puerto Rican? Are you [BLEEP] Puerto Rican?"
接下来我知道的是，他把我扔在地上。他把警棍抵在我的背上，人行道上的唾沫和口香糖沾在我脸上。他说，“你是什么？你是什么？你是波多黎各人吗？你是该死的波多黎各人吗？”
I said, "No, I'm not Puerto Rican. Yo, I'm selling Bart Simpson, OJ Simpson t-shirts. What's the problem, officer, right?" Well, see, he want to know what am I. My color is white like Bill Clinton, right? But that's not good enough for him, you know.
我说，“不，我不是波多黎各人。嘿，我是在卖巴特·辛普森、OJ·辛普森的T恤。有什么问题吗，长官，对吧？”嗯，看，他想知道我是什么。我的肤色像比尔·克林顿一样白，对吧？但这对他来说不够好，你知道。
And the way that I'm speaking. I don't even know. He got a complex. He needs to see a therapist because he's confused. Then he look in the t-shirts, he gets more confused. Because he don't know who's Bart Simpson.
还有我说话的方式。我甚至不知道。他有情结。他需要看心理医生，因为他很困惑。然后他看那些T恤，他更困惑了。因为他不知道谁是巴特·辛普森。
Nah, he knows Bart Simpson is Bart Simpson. But he don't know Bart Simpson is Dominican, Jewish, Greek, Puerto Rican. What is he, right? But he knows that Bart Simpson, OJ Simpson make more money than him, right? And then he looks at me, and he sees somebody that's an entrepreneur, that's trying to better his situation in life, right? That I have the opportunity to increase my status in the world or whatever you want to call it, right?
不，他知道巴特·辛普森是巴特·辛普森。但他不知道巴特·辛普森是多米尼加人、犹太人、希腊人、波多黎各人。他到底是什么，对吧？但他知道巴特·辛普森、OJ·辛普森比他挣钱多，对吧？然后他看着我，他看到了一个创业者，一个正在努力改善生活状况的人，对吧？我有机会提升我在世界上的地位，或者不管你想怎么称呼它，对吧？
And then he looks at himself. And he sees that he's just a servant, and that's it. And that's all you gonna be. Even if he become captain, police chief, lieutenant, whatever, he just a servant. So he feel threatened. So because he feel threatened, that day, he decided to make capitalism illegal, right?
然后他看着他自己。他看到他只是一个仆人，就是这样。这就是你能成为的一切。即使他成为队长、警察局长、中尉，不管怎样，他只是一个仆人。所以他感到被威胁。所以因为他感到被威胁，那天，他决定让资本主义违法，对吧？
And me, because I got a prior felony on my record, they put me in here. So you got a cigarette? Good lookin' out, man. Nah, if you think about it, if you analyze it with the little girl on the TV, right? If that's not America, that you can stand outside your house and sell whatever, don't advertise it then. You know? Don't put it in the [BLEEP] TV.
而我，因为我之前有重罪记录，他们把我关在这里。你有烟吗？谢了，伙计。不，如果你仔细想想，如果你用电视上的那个小女孩分析一下，对吧？如果那不是美国，那你可以站在房子外面卖任何东西，那就别做广告了。你知道吗？别他妈在电视上放。
To be honest with you, I seen that commercial. I got inspired by that [BLEEP]. Nah, since [BLEEP] ain't really that bad. I got chances or whatever, you know. And I'm in [BLEEP] jail, bro.
老实说，我看了那个广告。我受到了启发。不，因为那根本没那么糟。我有机会或者其他什么的，你知道。而我现在他妈的在监狱里，兄弟。
I feel like suing the lemonade mother [BLEEP], man. For false advertising. I know I wasn't selling lemonade. Yo, shut up, man. I didn't really ask you to respond and [BLEEP] Nah. Yo, you got a light?
我想起诉那个柠檬水混蛋，伙计。因为虚假广告。我知道我卖的不是柠檬水。嘿，闭嘴，伙计。我真的没让你回应。不。嘿，你有火吗？
Danny Hoch, writer and performer from his great one-man show Jails, Hospitals and Hip-Hop. The show is available on CD and in book form. His website, dannyhoch.com.
丹尼·霍克，作家兼表演者，来自他伟大的单人秀《监狱、医院和嘻哈》。演出可在CD和书籍形式获得。他的网站，dannyhoch.com。
[MUSIC - "TEN COMMANDMENTS OF BART" BY BART SIMPSON]
[音乐 - 巴特·辛普森的《巴特的十诫》]
Yeah, don't touch that dial. Coming up, if you become a salesman and your personality changes from what it was to something else, where you're suddenly able to charm most anybody, where you're not scared of people saying no to you, is that necessarily a good thing? A cautionary tale in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
是的，别动那个转盘。接下来，如果你成为一名推销员，你的性格从原来的样子变成了另一种样子，突然能够吸引几乎任何人，不怕别人对你说不，这一定是好事吗？一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，国际公共广播电台将带来一个警示故事。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers and reporters to tackle that theme. Today's program, Sales. America's greatest art form. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Who's The Man?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者和记者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，销售。美国最伟大的艺术形式。我们来到了我们节目的第三幕。第三幕，“谁才是大佬？”
There are many jobs that change you. We've all met grade school teachers who continue to talk like grade school teachers even when they are among adults at dinner parties. Or psychiatrists who never stop talking like psychiatrists, nothing duller really. Here's a story about how becoming a salesman, a salesman of radio ad time, changed one person.
有很多工作会改变你。我们都见过小学老师，即使在晚宴上与成年人在一起时，他们依然像小学老师一样说话。或者是从来不停止像精神科医生那样说话的精神科医生，真的没比这更无聊的了。这是一个关于成为一名推销员——一名广播广告时间推销员——如何改变一个人的故事。
I didn't want this job at all. I was working as a reporter. And they needed to fill this slot. And so they brought me in and said, "We're moving your salary to sales. And if you'd like to continue to receive that salary, we suggest you join it there." I think those were literally their words.
我根本不想做这份工作。我当时是做记者的。他们需要填补这个空缺。所以他们把我叫来说，“我们要把你调到销售部。如果你想继续领取那份工资，我们建议你加入那里。”我想这字面上就是他们的话。
How very graceful.
真是优雅。
So I decided I did want to keep that salary. I had a great first three weeks when I was first selling. I made every sale. And I remember talking to this friend of mine who was a real long-time veteran.
所以我决定我确实想保留那份工资。我刚开始销售的前三周过得很棒。我完成了每一笔交易。我记得和我的一个朋友交谈，他是一个真正的老手。
And he said, "You're doing it all wrong. You're doing it all wrong. If you make every sale, that means you're only going for the surest things. And there's just not that many sure things. So you're not going after enough money." He said, "The sign that you're succeeding is that you're making 8% of your sales, 10% of your sales. So it's really important to embrace them saying no. It means you're going far enough and deep enough."
他说，“你全做错了。你全做错了。如果你完成了每一笔交易，那意味着你只选择了最确定的事情。而确定事情没那么多。所以你没在追求足够的金钱。”他说，“你成功的标志应该是你只完成了你推销的8%，10%。所以拥抱被拒绝非常重要。这意味着你走得足够远、足够深。”
I had this boss who had been in sales his whole life. And he taught me that when I started feeling nervous, it probably meant they were feeling nervous. And that was good. And the more good I felt about it, the more control I had over both of our nervousnesses. And, therefore, if they were just blinded by it and afraid of it and I was encouraged by it and energized by it, then I just stood a better chance of coming out the winner.
我有个老板，他一辈子都在做销售。他教我，当我开始感到紧张时，可能意味着对方也感到紧张。那是件好事。我对它感觉越好，我就越能控制我们双方的紧张感。因此，如果他们只是被恐惧遮蔽，而我被它鼓舞、充满活力，那么我就更有机会成为赢家。
Suddenly, I'm going to these sales calls. And I can't wait. I'm running to these sales calls. I'm clicking the elevator button to make it come faster because I can't wait. Because-- it's all sorts of things.
突然间，我要去参加这些销售电话会议。我迫不及待了。我飞奔着去参加这些销售会议。我飞快地按电梯按钮让它快点来，因为我等不及了。因为——这是各种各样的事情。
It's a feeling of power. It's really fun to go into a meeting with three people who are much older than you, who make a lot more money than you, who have a lot more power in the world than you, and you know that you're going to be the guy in the room who's totally calm, and they're going to be really nervous. And I love that. I love just being the cool guy, being the calm guy.
这是一种力量感。走进一个会议室，面对三个比你年长得多、比你挣钱多得多、在世界上比你权力大得多的人，这真的很有趣，而且你知道你将成为房间里那个完全冷静的人，而他们会非常紧张。我喜欢那样。我喜欢做那个冷静的家伙。
And I loved creating these relationships, a type of relationship I've never had before, which is just this glib, friendly relationship based on complete empty chatter about the weather or TV. I developed this theory that those really popular TV shows, one major function is to provide conversation to Americans. And not conversation about the show, but the actual conversation of the show.
我喜欢创造这些关系，一种我从未有过的关系类型，也就是这种基于关于天气或电视的完全空洞闲聊的油嘴滑舌、友好的关系。我提出了一个理论，那些非常受欢迎的电视节目，一个主要功能是为美国人提供谈话资料。不是关于节目的谈话，而是节目本身的实际谈话。
You would just say, "Hey, do you remember last night when Kramer said that? Boy, that was funny. And remember when Elaine said this to Jerry? Oh, that was funny." I didn't know that people did that. People would do that to me. And then the next sales call, I'd do that to the next person. And they seemed to like it.
你只会说，“嘿，你记得昨晚克莱默说的话吗？天哪，那太搞笑了。还记得伊莱恩对杰瑞说的话吗？噢，那太搞笑了。”我不知道人们会那样做。人们会对我那样做。然后在下一次销售会议上，我会对下一个人那样做。他们似乎很喜欢。
I started realizing it doesn't matter what you say, it doesn't matter how vapid it is. All that mattered was that I felt comfortable and that I gave them the illusion of some kind of false intimacy. At first, I found it really great, really exciting and freeing.
我开始意识到你说什么并不重要，它有多无聊并不重要。唯一重要的是我感到舒服，而且我给了他们某种虚假亲密感的错觉。起初，我发现这真的很棒，真的很令人兴奋和解放。
It kind of amazed me. First of all, how quickly I just became this different person and how much I enjoyed it. I found I would do things that I hadn't done before. I would hold doors open for women. And I would wait on an elevator until all the women had gotten off.
这让我有点惊讶。首先，我如何迅速地变成了这个不同的人，以及我有多享受它。我发现我会做以前没做过的事情。我会为女士们扶门。我会等电梯直到所有女士都出来。
Or I would compliment people on their-- if a friend made a joke, I'd say, "That's very funny. That's a very amusing joke. It reminds me of a joke I once heard." And I'd use my hands in these ways that I had learned made people feel at ease, never folded over my chest, but open and inviting.
或者我会称赞人们——如果朋友讲了个笑话，我会说，“那太搞笑了。那是一个非常有趣的笑话。它让我想起我曾经听过的一个笑话。”我会用我学到的方式使用我的手，让人们感到放松，永远不要交叉在胸前，而是开放和邀请的姿态。
And my whole voice would change. My whole affect would change to the point where, when I would hang out with my friends, they'd make fun of me. "Why are you so formal? Why are you so fake?"
我的整个声音都会改变。我的整个情感流露会改变，以至于当我和朋友出去玩时，他们会取笑我。“你为什么这么拘谨？你为什么这么假？”
When your friends would say these things about how you were changing, were you in any way alarmed?
当你的朋友说这些关于你是如何改变的话时，你感到惊慌了吗？
No, I loved it. I felt like I had superpowers. I could go anywhere and talk to whoever I wanted and not give a [BLEEP]. I had always had trouble with women. I'd always had a hard time asking them out. And suddenly, I was asking out anyone. It didn't matter to me. But I just felt like I could put on this persona, and, at least in my mind, it was smooth. And people liked that person. And I liked it.
不，我爱死它了。我觉得我有超能力。我可以去任何地方，和我想交谈的任何人交谈，而且完全不在乎。我以前和女性相处总是有麻烦。我一直很难开口约她们。突然间，我在约任何人。对我来说没区别。但我只是觉得我可以戴上这个人设，至少在我心里，这很顺畅。人们喜欢那个人。我也喜欢。
There's something essentially optimistic about being a salesman. It seems very American, very forward thinking. A no is an opportunity. It's an opportunity to learn why you got that no, what went wrong there, how you can do better.
作为一名推销员，本质上有一种乐观主义。这看起来非常美国化，非常有前瞻性。一个“不”就是一个机会。这是一个了解为什么你得到那个“不”、哪里出了问题、你如何能做得更好的机会。
So there's this notion of self-improvement?
所以这有一个自我提升的概念？
Yeah. There were a few times where this whole process really felt like the violation of something. It felt like I went too far. There was this guy who was president of a major company. And he wanted to buy what turned out to be a lot of money in ads. And it would mean a lot of money to me personally and a lot to the station.
是的。有几次这个整个过程真的感觉像对某种东西的亵渎。感觉我走得太远了。有个家伙是一家大公司的总裁。他想买后来证明是一大笔广告费的东西。这对我个人和电台来说意味着一大笔钱。
And it was a big decision for him because, even though he was the president, he was trying to establish his own base within the company. And they didn't want him to be on this particular station. They didn't think he should be.
对他来说这是一个重大决定，因为即使他是总裁，他也在努力在公司内建立自己的基础。他们不想让他上这个特定的电台。他们认为他不应该上。
And I felt like I had always known his company shouldn't be on our air. I knew we weren't going to sell that product. But I prepared the charts that made it seem like we would. And I gave him the ammunition and the encouragement to fight the good fight. And he was really fighting for it.
我觉得我一直都知道他的公司不应该在我们的频道。我知道我们不会卖掉那个产品。但我准备了图表，让它看起来好像我们会卖。我给了他武器和鼓励去打这场好仗。他真的在为它而战。
There's this one moment where he and I went out for drinks at this private men's club, which was another part of this whole ridiculous life that I had for that period of time, was belonging to a private-- not men's club-- private club. And he was really opening up. He was really talking about his wife, and their relationship, and his fears of being in this job, and whether or not he wanted to have kids, and what that would mean to him, and how he ended up being a businessman, and what other kinds of lifes he could have led, and sometimes wished he had led. And it was so awful because he really bought my false intimacy. He really saw us as friends.
有那么一刻，我和他在这个私人男士俱乐部喝了酒，这是我那段荒唐生活的一部分，属于一个私人——不是男士俱乐部——私人俱乐部。他真的敞开了心扉。他真的谈到了他的妻子、他们的关系、他在这份工作中的恐惧、他是否想生孩子、这对意味着什么、他最终是如何成为商人的、他还可能过什么样的生活，有时希望他曾经那样做过。这太糟糕了，因为他真的买账了我的虚假亲密感。他真的把我们视为朋友。
To be honest, I had had these moments before. I'd even gone to clients' homes for dinner to meet their family. I started finding that when I hit these moments of false intimacy-- there were a few stories from my childhood or a few set pieces that seemed like they were emotional sharing, but really were just set pieces that I felt very comfortable uttering. I probably said them almost word-for-word, verbatim each time. But they gave the illusion of opening up.
老实说，我以前也有过这些时刻。我甚至去过客户家吃晚饭见他们的家人。我开始发现当我达到这些虚假亲密时刻时——有一些来自我童年的故事或一些看起来像是情感分享的固定桥段，但实际上只是我觉得说起来非常舒服的固定桥段。我可能每次都几乎逐字逐句地说出来。但它们给了人们一种敞开心扉的错觉。
And so I threw a couple of those at him. But I just knew he would never be a friend. I would never open up to him in that way, in an authentic way. And I couldn't tell him, "You know what? You shouldn't be on our air." Because he'd probably sue us. Or who knows what?
所以我向他抛出了一些。但我只是知道他永远不会成为朋友。我永远不会以那种方式、以真实的方式对他敞开心扉。而且我不能告诉他，“你知道吗？你不应该出现在我们的频道。”因为他可能会起诉我们。或者谁知道呢？
Because he was already on your air?
因为他已经出现在你的频道上了？
He was already on my air. And I wanted his money. I did. It meant a lot of money to me. And I couldn't tell him that I didn't want to be his friend. What would be the point of that?
他已经出现在我的频道上了。而且我想要他的钱。我是这么想的。它对我来说意味着一大笔钱。而且我不能告诉他我不愿意做他的朋友。那有什么意义呢？
And I just remember feeling just stuck, like I didn't know-- There didn't seem to be any way to deal with him honorably.
我只记得感觉被困住了，就像我不知道——似乎没有任何办法能体面地处理他。
So what did you do?
那你做了什么？
I kept selling to him. And eventually, he left that company. And I never knew if he got fired or if he quit on his own. I never knew if it had anything to do with us.
我继续向他销售。最终，他离开了那家公司。我永远不知道他是被解雇了还是自己辞职的。我永远不知道这是否与我们有关。
He might have lost his job over that money.
他可能因为那笔钱丢了工作。
Yeah, it's possible. I don't know. Yeah.
是的，有可能。我不知道。是的。
And he trusted you?
他信任你？
Yeah. At the end of the day, you have to decide, look, it's their money. They're spending the money. And if they're spending the money based on the information I've given them, and only the information I've given them, then it's their fault. Shame on them for not doing the research and not seeking advisors.
是的。在一天结束时，你必须决定，看，那是他们的钱。他们在花钱。如果他们是根据我提供的信息在花钱，而且只根据我提供的信息，那么那是他们的错。怪他们没有做研究，没有寻求建议。
Of course, that's like saying, shame on them for believing me.
当然，这就像是说，怪他们相信我。
Right. Yeah, it is. But you say that a lot.
对。是的，确实是。但你经常这么说。
Act Four, The Secret To Being Rich And Happy. There are usually only two stories we Americans tell ourselves about our salesmen, about our own lives as salesmen. There's the super salesman story. Picture, please, the early days of Donald Trump. And there's the tragic, down-on-his-luck salesman. Picture the man in anything by, say, David Mamet.
第四幕，“富有且快乐的秘诀”。我们美国人讲述我们自己的推销员、我们作为推销员的生活的故事通常只有两个。一个是超级推销员的故事。请想象一下唐纳德·特朗普的早年。另一个是运气不佳的悲剧推销员。请想象一下大卫·马梅特任何作品中的人。
For a more accurate look at the life of an American salesman, consider, please, Jimmy Roy. "Diamond" Jimmy Roy. 76 years old. Lives and works in a town not far from Pittsburgh. He has sold everything from used cars to antiques to jewelry, all with a philosophy of sales that he has created himself, as many salesmen have to create a philosophy for themselves, to get themselves through it. Reporter Dan Collison hung around him for a few days.
为了更准确地观察美国推销员的生活，请考虑一下吉米·罗。“钻石”吉米·罗。76岁。在离匹兹堡不远的城镇生活和工作。他卖过从二手车到古董到珠宝的所有东西，带着他自己创造的销售哲学，正如许多推销员必须为自己创造一种哲学来支撑自己一样。记者丹·科里森在他身边待了几天。
As Jimmy Roy tells it, there was a time in the 1950s and '60s when he owned the town, the town of Braddock, Pennsylvania, located just downriver from Pittsburgh. But not everyone in Braddock remembers those days.
正如吉米·罗所说，在20世纪50年代和60年代，有一段时间他拥有那个城镇，即宾夕法尼亚州的布拉多克，就在匹兹堡下游。但并不是布拉多克的每个人都记得那些日子。
How you doing?
你好吗？
You know me?
你认识我吗？
Huh?
嗯？
You know me?
你认识我吗？
No, I do not.
不，我不认识。
J. Roy.
J. 罗。
My name is Clifton Nelson.
我的名字是克利夫顿·尼尔森。
OK. You're not from around here, are you?
好的。你不是本地人，对吧？
Yes, I am. Clifton Lamont Nelson, Junior.
是的，我是。克利夫顿·拉蒙特·尼尔森，小。
And you don't know J. Roy that used to own all the property here?
你不认识曾经拥有这里所有房产的J. 罗？
No, sir.
不，先生。
Automobile business and everything?
汽车生意什么的？
No, sir.
不，先生。
OK. Used to own a car lot over here. Owned this building here. Owned that house over here. Owned the Dillinger building, the furniture stores down here, the two furniture stores. I owned The Chicken Shack. You know The Chicken Shack on Fifth Street?
好的。曾经在这儿有个车行。拥有这里的这栋楼。拥有那边的那栋房子。拥有迪林格大楼、这边的家具店、那两家家具店。我拥有“鸡肉棚”。你知道第五街的“鸡肉棚”吗？
I think I know of it. I think I know it.
我想我知道。我想我知道它。
And I forget what else I owned.
我忘了我还拥有什么了。
Back then, Braddock was known as the "valley's greatest shopping center." On Saturdays, people would come from all over, and the sidewalks were jammed with shoppers. Then the steel mills started shutting down. People moved away. Suburban malls sprang up. And no one came to Braddock anymore.
那时，布拉多克被称为“山谷最伟大的购物中心”。周六，人们从四面八方赶来，人行道上挤满了购物者。后来钢铁厂开始关闭。人们搬走了。郊区购物中心兴起了。再也没人来布拉多克了。
[SINGING] Every time it rains, it rains pennies from heaven. Don't you know each cloud contains pennies from heaven?
[唱歌] 每当下雨时，天堂就下起便士。难道你不知道每朵云都包含着来自天堂的便士吗？
By the mid-'70s, Braddock was becoming a ghost town. It was about this time that filmmaker Tony Buba featured Jimmy Roy in one of his short documentaries on Braddock. That's Jimmy there singing. The occasion was the grand opening of J. Roy's Flea Market and New and Used Furniture Store. His other businesses had died. It was Jimmy's last stand.
到70年代中期，布拉多克正变成一座鬼城。大约就在那时，电影制片人托尼·布巴在他关于布拉多克的短纪录片中以吉米·罗为主角。那是吉米在唱歌。当时是J. 罗跳蚤市场和新旧家具店的盛大开业。他的其他生意都死了。这是吉米的背水一战。
What's so good about this building is we have a drive-in ramp, where we can hold about 50 used cars up there. And the future plan, we're going to put a drive-in used car lot, plus a drive-in used and new furniture store upstairs. The nice thing about it is people will able to drive right in, get out of their car, look at some used cars, look at antiques, look at new furniture, and look at used furniture. And I really believe that this time I've struck on something that people really need.
这栋楼最好的是我们有一个免下车坡道，我们可以在上面容纳50辆二手车。未来的计划是，我们要建立一个免下车二手车行，外加楼上的免下车二手和新家具店。好的是人们可以直接开车进来，下车，看看二手车，看看古董，看看新家具，看看二手家具。我真的相信这次我找到了人们真正需要的东西。
But I think we'll have no problem here in making it go. And I believe after that, that it's going to be Easy Street. I really believe that Saturday is going to mark a big day in my life. The grand opening of the J. Roy Flea Market and New and Used Furniture.
我想我们会在这里顺利运作。我相信在那之后，这就是“轻松街”了。我真的相信周六将标志着我生命中的重要一天。J. 罗跳蚤市场和新旧家具店的盛大开业。
Today, the street sign at the corner of Verona and Braddock Avenue, where the store was located, is so rusted out, it can't be read. J. Roy's Flea Market and New and Used Furniture didn't quite live up to Jimmy's expectations.
今天，维罗纳和布拉多克大道拐角处的街道标志，也就是商店所在的地方，锈迹斑斑，已经无法辨认了。J. 罗跳蚤市场和新旧家具店并没有完全达到吉米的期望。
I bet everything I had. And I bet my last penny, what I could borrow, and everything else. I bet it on this town. I bought everything. I stretched myself out to the last penny. I bet on it. I had no fear. But when I saw I had to face reality, everyone started to be scared to come to the town. You can't sell people who don't come to the town. So I figured I better get out while I can get out alive. So I did.
我押上了我拥有的一切。我押上了我最后一分钱，我能借到的一切，以及其他所有东西。我把一切都押在这个镇上了。我买下了一切。我伸展到了最后一分钱。我押上了它。我没有恐惧。但当我看到我必须面对现实时，每个人都开始害怕来这个镇。你不能把东西卖给不来这个镇的人。所以我认为我最好在活着的时候赶紧离开。所以我做了。
I go along with Shakespeare, "Nothing is good or bad, except thinking makes it so." Or the so-called words of Jesus. He says, "As a man thinketh in his heart, so is he." They musta knew something.
我同意莎士比亚的观点，“事物本身没有好坏之分，全在于人们的思想。”或者耶稣那所谓的名言。他说，“人心里怎么想，他就是怎样的人。”他们一定知道些什么。
These days, if you're looking for Jimmy Roy, chances are you'll find him at the Plaza Restaurant, just over the hill from Braddock. The Plaza is sort of like Jimmy's office. It's located in a 1960s strip mall next to a Shop and Save. It's the kind of family place with racks of pies in a glass case by the front door and where waitresses and their daughters work side by side.
这些天，如果你在找吉米·罗，很有可能你会在广场餐厅找到他，就在布拉多克的小山那边。广场餐厅有点像吉米的办公室。它位于Shop and Save旁边的60年代条状购物中心。这是那种家庭式的餐馆，前门有个玻璃柜架着馅饼，女服务员和她们的女儿并肩工作。
Jimmy Roy sits in a booth in the back of the smoking section. He's dressed in a white fedora, a white linen jacket with a maroon, silk handkerchief, a colorful tie with a diamond stick pin, and black and white alligator-skin shoes. He's wearing five diamond studded gold necklaces, two gold bracelets on each wrist, and he has diamond rings on every finger.
吉米·罗坐在吸烟区后面的一张隔间里。他戴着白色软呢帽，穿着白色亚麻外套，配着栗色丝绸手帕，系着色彩鲜艳的领带，上面别着钻石针，穿着黑白鳄鱼皮鞋。他戴着五条镶钻金项链，每个手腕上有两条金手镯，每个手指都戴着钻戒。
These are just some of the things I pick up when I sell, right off my hand. This is a little cluster, a men's pinkie ring. This is another cluster, index ring. They're not the most expensive, but they're diamonds. This is another cluster. And this is a emerald.
这些只是我在销售时顺手买的一些东西。这是一个小簇，男士小指戒指。这是另一个簇，食指戒指。它们不是最贵的，但它们是钻石。这是另一个簇。这是一个祖母绿。
Yeah, that's my store now. That's the store. I operate my stores. No overhead there. I don't have to pay rent.
是的，那就是我现在的商店。那就是商店。我经营我的商店。那里没有间接成本。我不用付租金。
This kind of change of fortune, going from owning virtually half of Braddock to hustling jewelry from a restaurant booth, is the sort of thing that might crush other men. Not Jimmy Roy. He's steeled himself against hardship with a philosophy of salesmanship that's more like a philosophy of life that he's been refining for decades.
这种命运的改变，从拥有布拉多克的一半财产到在餐馆隔间里推销珠宝，可能会压垮其他人。吉米·罗不会。他用一种销售哲学使自己免受苦难，这更像是一种他已经提炼了几十年的生活哲学。
I think it's the mind. I'm so convinced that for 42 years of some studying of the mind, the mind is the most important thing we have. The mind is the directing force of thinking, is responsible for where you're going, whether you're going to be successful, whether you're going to be a failure.
我认为这是心灵的作用。我坚信，在42年的心灵研究中，心灵是我们拥有的最重要的东西。心灵是思想的指挥力量，决定了你的去向，你是会成功，还是会失败。
To Jimmy, it's all very simple. You tell yourself who you want to be, what you want to be. And if you do these positive visualizations long enough, great things will happen to you. It goes like this.
对吉米来说，一切都很简单。你告诉自己你想成为谁，你想成为什么。如果你进行这些积极的可视化足够长的时间，伟大的事情就会发生在你身上。它是这样进行的。
Early in the morning when you rise, you feed yourself great thoughts, such as concentration, peace, poise, non-resistance, achievement, vitality, strength, life, youth. You feed yourself these thoughts before you leave the house. And don't concern yourself about how these thoughts are gonna manifest the beauty that you'll receive from planting the great thoughts in your mind, no more than you would be concerned about planting a tomato seed. Once you plant it, you're unconcerned. You know you planted in nice dirt and nice ground. You know that you will receive your tomatoes. To control your thinking is to control your life, control your success.
清晨起床时，你给自己注入伟大的思想，例如专注、平静、镇定、不抗拒、成就、活力、力量、生命、青春。你在离家之前给自己注入这些思想。不要担心这些思想会如何显现，正如你不会担心播下番茄种子会带来你从播下伟大思想的心灵中收到的美。一旦你播下了它，你就不用担心了。你知道你种在好土里。你知道你会收到你的番茄。控制你的思想就是控制你的生活，控制你的成功。
I'm wanted on the phone. I'm wanted on the phone. Excuse me.
电话找我。电话找我。请原谅。
His regular customers reach him on the Plaza's pay phone to set up appointments.
他的常客会在广场餐厅的公用电话上联系他来预约。
Hello? Yeah, That's be fine. What time? Between 10:00 and 11:00. That'll be fine. Right.
喂？是的，那很好。什么时间？10点到11点之间。那很好。好的。
I'm glad you called. I'm glad you're all right. Yeah, we were worried sick about you.
我很高兴你打电话。我很高兴你没事。是的，我们为你担心死了。
Jimmy got his start in sales at the age of 22 in the used car business. Just home from World War II, he was determined to stay out of the steel mills, where he worked as a teenager and where most of his friends were headed. He quit his first sales job after just a week because his dealership was ripping off customers. He's tried to be more honest. He's been a salesman for 54 years.
吉米22岁时在二手车生意中开始了他的销售生涯。刚从二战回家，他决心远离他十几岁时工作且他大多数朋友都去往的钢铁厂。他只做了一周的第一次销售工作就辞职了，因为他的车行在欺骗顾客。他试着表现得更诚实。他已经做了54年的推销员。
Hi, sweetheart. How you doing? How you doing? How you doing?
嗨，亲爱的。你好吗？你好吗？你好吗？
On the way out of the Plaza, Jimmy stops to admire a baby.
在离开广场餐厅的路上，吉米停下来欣赏一个婴儿。
Besides being beautiful, how do you feel? You look great.
除了漂亮，你感觉如何？你看上去棒极了。
Say, "Thank you."
说，“谢谢”。
You look great. You look good. You look like a good girl.
你看上去棒极了。你看上去不错。你看上去是个好女孩。
It's an old salesman trick. Win over the parents by flattering their kids.
这是一个老推销员的把戏。通过奉承他们的孩子来赢得父母的心。
May I give her a lucky dollar?
我能给她一个幸运币吗？
Put it in her piggy bank when we get home.
我们回家后把它放进她的存钱罐里。
Put it in your piggy bank?
放进你的小猪存钱罐？
Or your horsey bank?
还是你的小马存钱罐？
Does she chew bubble gum? I got bubble gum for her.
她吃泡泡糖吗？我这儿有泡泡糖给她。
That makes me feel so bad and good. It's unexplainable. I make a baby smile. It makes me feel so great. Honest to god.
这让我感觉既糟又好。无法解释。我让一个婴儿笑了。这让我感觉太棒了。向上帝发誓。
Jimmy drives a gray 1990 Lincoln town car, loaded up with boxes full of bubble gum and fruit exactly for moments like this. He calls them his "giveaways." His dashboard is plastered with scraps of paper printed with motivational aphorisms.
吉米开着一辆灰色的1990年林肯轿车，里面装满了专门为这种时刻准备的泡泡糖和水果盒。他称它们为他的“赠品”。他的仪表盘上贴满了印着励志名言的纸条。
You are very fortunate if you have learned that the most certain way to get is to first give. Choosing to develop an intelligent level of yourself and all of mankind will motivate you to accomplishments above and beyond your expectations. Maintain a positive mental attitude to achieve mental and physical health and to live a longer life. Every day, in every way, I'm getting better and better. And see, all we gotta do is accent the positive.
如果你了解到获得的最可靠方法是先给予，那么你非常幸运。选择发展一个理性的自我和全人类水平，将激励你取得超出你预期的成就。保持积极的心态以获得心理和生理健康并活得更长久。每天，在各个方面，我都在变得越来越好。你看，我们所要做的就是强调积极的一面。
For years, Jimmy Roy has given motivational seminars, where he preaches his philosophy of life. Recently, about 70 people packed the back room at the Plaza Restaurant to hear him give the latest version, entitled "The Secret of Being Rich and Happy." He also gave the seminar to salesmen at Parkway Ford, an auto dealership just up the road from the Plaza. Today, he's back to hand out some cufflinks.
多年来，吉米·罗举办过励志研讨会，向人们宣扬他的生活哲学。最近，大约70人挤满了广场餐厅的后厅，听他发表题为“富有且快乐的秘诀”的最新演讲。他还向广场餐厅路上的Parkway福特汽车经销商的推销员举办了这次研讨会。今天，他回来派发一些袖扣。
That's it. Merry Christmas.
就是这样。圣诞快乐。
Thank you, sir. I appreciate it.
谢谢，先生。我很感激。
You're welcome.
不客气。
And to see how his motivational talk went over.
看看他的励志演讲效果如何。
It was a very, very inspirational speech, very, very motivating. And the guys been rocking ever since. Sales went up.
这是一个非常、非常鼓舞人心的演讲，非常、非常激励人。伙计们从那以后一直很带劲。销量上升了。
I'm glad to hear that.
我很高兴听到这个。
It's a little hard to tell whether these salesmen are sincere or whether they're just humoring Jimmy. But they seem to truly like him. And why wouldn't they? The proof is in the numbers. Sales at Parkway Ford did, in fact, increase by 10% after Jimmy's seminar.
很难说这些推销员是真诚的，还是只是在迁就吉米。但他们似乎真的很喜欢他。为什么不呢？证据就在数字里。吉米的研讨会后，Parkway福特的销售额确实增长了10%。
What are some of the things that he told us?
他告诉你们的一些事情是什么？
Peace.
和平。
I am peace. I am harmony. I am goodwill. I am--
我是和平。我是和谐。我是善意。我是——
Poise.
镇定。
I am law. I am order.
我是法则。我是秩序。
I am spiritual.
我是精神性的。
I am spiritual. I'm vitality. I'm understanding. I am successful.
我是精神性的。我是活力。我是理解。我是成功的。
And is it working for you?
这对你有用吗？
It's working great. He comes by, and man, we pumped up.
效果很好。他过来，伙计，我们充满了动力。
You're all pumped up when you leave the house.
你们离家时都充满了动力。
Without a doubt.
毫无疑问。
See, you feed the mind. The mind is the dynamo that supplies the power. Your thinking is a directing force of that power. And when you have all these things being directed, it's impossible to fail. You cannot fail.
你看，你滋养了心灵。心灵是提供能量的发电机。你的思想是那种能量的指挥力量。当你拥有所有这些东西被指挥时，是不可能失败的。你不可能失败。
You cannot fail.
你不可能失败。
That's right.
说得对。
Naturally, as he leaves Parkway Ford, there's business to do. One of the car salesmen wants to look at an engagement ring.
自然，当他离开Parkway福特时，有生意要做。其中一位汽车推销员想看看订婚戒指。
That's a marquis in the center.
中间是一个马眼钻。
It's a wide band.
这是一个宽圈。
With the wide band. We have that.
带着宽圈。我们有那个。
Jimmy does deals like this because after 54 years as a salesman, it's who he is. He has to sell. When he tried to quit a few years back, he says, he nearly lost his mind.
吉米做这样的交易，因为在做了54年推销员之后，这就是他。他必须销售。他说，当他几年前试图辞职时，他几乎疯了。
Well, that seems to be a sure sale there because he inquired about it before. And he seems to be very sincere. I can generally tell when it's a sell. I just look at them, and I study-- being that there's only one mind in the universe, his mind and my mind are identical. And if I concentrate hard enough, I can walk right into his mind and feel what he's thinking. It's a great advantage, not to be abused, but to be used.
嗯，那看起来是一笔确定的交易，因为他之前打听过。而且他看起来非常真诚。我通常能看出什么时候是一笔生意。我只是看着他们，我研究——既然宇宙中只有一个心灵，他的心灵和我的心灵是完全一样的。如果我集中注意力足够久，我就能直接走进他的心灵，感受他在想什么。这是一个巨大的优势，不是为了滥用，而是为了使用。
So you're saying, you can actually read his mind.
所以你是说，你真的能读懂他的心思。
Many times. If you concentrate hard enough, you can reach right in there and feel whether he's telling you the truth or he's lying. I believe that all of us have that, but very few use it.
很多次。如果你集中注意力足够久，你就能触及那里，感受他是在告诉你真相还是在撒谎。我相信我们所有人都有这个能力，但很少有人使用它。
Jimmy says, he'd like to take his seminar-- "The Secret of Being Rich and Happy"-- on the road. He's writing a book by the same name, though he has no publisher. Of course, Jimmy's philosophy hasn't actually made him rich. And as I hung around him, I kept trying to figure out a polite way to ask him about this.
吉米说，他想带着他的研讨会——“富有且快乐的秘诀”——去巡回。他正在写一本同样名字的书，虽然他没有出版商。当然，吉米的哲学并没有让他真正变得富有。当我在他身边待着时，我一直在想办法找个礼貌的方式问他这个问题。
Jimmy, there's a question I've been wanting to ask you for a while that's been bothering me a little bit. The name of your seminar and the name of the book you're working on is "The Secret of Being Rich and Happy." But, with all due respect, you're not rich.
吉米，有一个问题我想问你有一段时间了，它让我有点困扰。你的研讨会和你在写的那本书的名字是“富有且快乐的秘诀”。但是，恕我直言，你并不富有。
Well, I think I'm one of the richest men in the world. I'm so abundantly blessed in more respects than money. I have money. I have some money. And I have health and happiness with me. I have things that money can't buy.
嗯，我认为我是世界上最富有的人之一。我在金钱以外的许多方面都得到了极其丰富的祝福。我有钱。我有一些钱。我有健康和幸福。我有金钱买不到的东西。
Why don't you call it "The Secret of Being Happy?"
你为什么不叫它“快乐的秘诀”？
Well, because you're rich when you are happy. We could use that title. But that seemed to come from within me, "The Secret of Becoming Rich and Happy." Well, I'll tell you the truth.
嗯，因为当你快乐时你就是富有的。我们可以用那个标题。但这似乎来自我的内心，“富有且快乐的秘诀”。嗯，我告诉你真相。
Another reason why I used the word "rich," I'm going to be very honest, most people desire to be rich. So I figured it would sell more books, to be very honest with you, by them seeing how the secret of becoming rich and happy. I believe it'll sell more books.
我使用“富有”这个词的另一个原因，我要非常诚实，大多数人都渴望富有。所以我认为如果你看到“富有且快乐的秘诀”，那会卖出更多的书，跟你说实话。我相信它会卖出更多的书。
But somehow, I can't believe that you wouldn't want to be more wealthy, that you wouldn't want to be rich.
但无论如何，我无法相信你不想变得更富有，不想变得富有。
Oh, excuse me. I never said I didn't want personal wealth. I think you misunderstood me. I like to have enough, like I have now, to live comfortable, and to eat good, and to have a nice place to stay. And I like money in my pocket.
噢，原谅我。我从来没说过我不想要个人财富。我想你误解我了。我喜欢拥有足够的，就像我现在拥有的，过得舒适，吃得好，有地方住。我喜欢口袋里有钱。
I like to give. And I have that. And I don't think there's a richer man in the world than I am as far as the state of mind is concerned. I believe I have the best state of mind in the universe, in my honest to god opinion.
我喜欢给予。我拥有这些。我不认为世界上还有比我更富有的人，就心态而言。我相信我有宇宙中最好的心态，以我向上帝发誓的观点。
By and large, Jimmy does seem genuinely happy. Ask anyone in Braddock. Filmmaker Tony Buba, who's known him just about all his life, says he's never seen Jimmy down. But consider this. The philosophy that's made Jimmy happy may be one of the things that's kept him from being rich. Tony says the reason Jimmy isn't wealthy is because he's too honest.
总的来说，吉米似乎确实很开心。问问布拉多克的任何人。几乎一生都认识他的电影制片人托尼·布巴说，他从没见过吉米低落。但请考虑一下。让吉米快乐的哲学可能是让他无法变得富有的原因之一。托尼说吉米不富有的原因是他太诚实了。
What I think is he doesn't have that thievery in him. Because I think if he had that thievery, if he had that edge of not really caring about other people, then he probably could have been a millionaire.
我认为他身上没有那种小偷小摸的劲头。因为我想如果他有那种小偷小摸的劲头，如果他有那种不在乎其他人的优势，那么他可能早就成了百万富翁了。
I could have probably been a multimillionaire if I wanted to go the wrong way. Because I had the opportunity to cheat people in the automobile business and different businesses I had. But I never would be comfortable. I think I would've been what they call a poor rich man.
如果我想走歪门邪道，我可能早就成了千万富翁了。因为我在汽车行业和其他经营的生意中有机会欺骗别人。但我永远不会感到舒服。我想我当时会成为他们所说的“贫穷的富人”。
People might think, "Oh, Jimmy, Jimmy." Nobody'll walk away from the man. He has a lot of friends. And everybody likes him. Because he's never cheated anybody.
人们可能会想，“哦，吉米，吉米。”没人会远离这个人。他有很多朋友。每个人都喜欢他。因为他从来没欺骗过任何人。
"The Very Thought of You." [SINGING] The very thought of and I forget to do the little ordinary things that everyone ought to do.
“想到你”。[唱歌] 想到……我忘了做每个人都应该做的那些小事。
Our final stop is Moray's Lounge, an upscale piano bar near downtown Pittsburgh. Jimmy comes here to have a few drinks, to listen to Shirley, who's been playing the lounge for almost 20 years, and, every once in a while, to sing a song.
我们的最后一站是莫雷酒廊，匹兹堡市中心附近的一家高档钢琴酒吧。吉米来这里喝几杯酒，听听已经在酒廊演奏了近20年的雪莉的音乐，偶尔唱上一首歌。
It's tempting to see salesmen like Jimmy Roy as kind of tragic Willy Loman characters. But here at Moray's Lounge, people recognize Jimmy. They call him "Diamond" Jim. He chats with Shirley. He chats with the bartender. His philosophy seems to be working. He looks as happy as a man can be.
把吉米·罗这样的推销员看作威利·洛曼式的悲剧人物很有诱惑力。但在这里的莫雷酒廊，人们认得吉米。他们叫他“钻石”吉米。他和雪莉聊天。他和酒保聊天。他的哲学似乎行得通。他看起来是一个人所能达到的最快乐的样子。
That story by Dan Collison.
丹·科里森的故事。
Well, our program produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Speigel, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus. Marketing by [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
嗯，我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、苏珊·伯顿和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作协助豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴克曼和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。营销由[听不清]负责。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago. We are selling right now. 312-832-3380. Buy, buy, buy. But you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Picture of Jimmy Roy there this week. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买这期节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台。我们现在正在销售。312-832-3380。买，买，买。但你知道你可以免费在互联网上我们的网站 www.thislife.org 收听我们的大部分节目。本周网站上有吉米·罗的照片。感谢负责运营网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who actually has his own philosophy for selling This American Life to new stations.
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他本人实际上有一套向新电台推销《美国生活》的哲学。
It doesn't matter what you say, it doesn't matter how vapid it is.
你说什么并不重要，它有多无聊并不重要。
But the key line that sold it was to then say, "In other words, Mr. Executive, it's basically Jaws on paws."
但卖掉它的关键台词是说：“换句话说，高管先生，这基本上就是装了爪子的《大白鲨》。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。